he was the closest one came up to and
contested Rose loses the basket and
robbed in John's get that shot on here
dive on the loose ball welcome project
it proves that pressure against him kind
of like the martial arts move these
their aggressiveness against them
there's like somebody highlights it's
hard to keep up run maybe just takes
this and takes it to the class and puffs
it do these great videos and so he loves
judge judy they did a spinoff of that he
has no blocks town for three no chance
for Jordan to block that one yes so so
he's got five tonight know what I need
to get it back preferably to a
one-possession game and they do that up
to three from town's getting towns over
the top of flare screen and Dwight
Powell gets caught up on itas Gibson
scream Carl just escaped dribbles to
below the break and that D was an open
dunk that play and then the rebound that
went out about all of the ways
aggressively going after the ball
speaking of aggressive while Anthony
towels with authorities three-point
attempt to a season
underneath us he's dug Begley in the
hole right back at you and timber was
built an early 12-point lead but the
keys right now are coming roaring back
karl-anthony towns leading all border
towns one-legged fadeaway
[Applause]
back to towns season-opening go to the
free-throw line here slice it in half
towns fires the three unable to connect
Wiggins the tap back towns for the two
and it will drop but the Lawrence sounds
and that's going to close the game shot
clock down to two towns has got a hurry
fadeaway
and that shot goes in that shot goes in
either way jump shot as the shot clock
is winding down
Kimbrel just doesn't do a lot else well
he talks which I guess the scoring good
ducking speaking of put a fine bite jeff
Teague the Dwyane Wade and that whole
dynamic was is not good for Fred to
let's forget the Porta sabirah touch
thing bringing a rajon rondo
[Applause]
badly needed
sharukh somebody needs to get it away a
towns does and he's able to get it to go
right as the shot clock expired Herbie
but he was on a federal minimum Tyson
Chandler JaVale McGee gets the bucket at
the damaged towns this was oppressive
good friends char a hand comes up with a
steal for Ashanti let's go back to the
Sharks saved to Derrick Rose to the
alley who passed karl-anthony towns
anticipation by talents because I don't
think you assure that Derrick Rose is
gonna throw that one out
andrew wiggins right behind him at 5.7
charlotte's comes up with the basketball
Tyus Jones leaving Englert ABS put that
on your highlight reel all these nice
young players like these role players
that Chicago
to the front of the room in towns finds
him fancy but it's so effective again
towns just off the block and he creaks
and has so much murder taken away by
towns
Rose has Trey young - Pete gets the step
bottom and the finished dumb it does
have as many as five made threes in game
this season which is a career best
Devon was grabbing Carl right here -
that could have been a foul towns has
eight and the forks and has got it real
shark was alone in the corner
momentarily tap says I'll just handle it
from here
that was crazy gone back to town look at
the defenders who are coming to collapse
on towns what pass over the shoulder my
task you're cutting charge tired this
runs right into the chest of Julius
Randle again nice cut it in this quarter
towns with five on the clock the step
back is pure and the lead is down to six
towns with 24 points in other words he
showed remarkable restraint in Cypress
towns oh wow towns get Chevy Oh Sheila
Peggy in a bad position
my goodness it's bringing some malicious
intentions with that slant this six
advantage of the quarter so far close
out the quarter was fifty collapse the
defense and you got a lot of yellow
jerseys right there to be on the key to
come right in the face the Detroit
Pistons Utah and then back home for a
game against Cleveland
drinka tell karl-anthony towns the
putback doctor his duck as the town's
putback Andrew Wiggins from the left
corner normally a spot as we've seen
today where he knocks down shots and
that thing was soft
[Music]
[Applause]
was it out perfect oh well again what
elevation by cat it's an elevated for
this melody towns just look into the
middle of the floor you could go back
and you can find a montage that James
Worthy
[Music]
town gets around Weibo oh my goodness
karl-anthony towns on the call look at
town with the snow pace line underneath
the blue pin Carl gets Jones and how
about Titus getting run here at the end
of the game Jeff Teague you don't know
if that bothers
[Applause]
and really short hey this is the guys
can have an impact in this league
challenge finally gets on the board
started his little two-man game he was
anticipating a little hot down votes the
paint this is nicely done Derrick Rose
Bayless finally gets it into town but
that just destroys the rim right now
karl-anthony towns in the tip rolls on
the short end of a six-point game keep
vision in towns and maybe even double
off the post top puts a move off
and wrote it down see that's what makes
me want to play it's those type of plays
that make you miss basketball
five to shoot town attacking go back it
does slam it down
I mean I didn't expect Carlton get told
that was a world there he just put that
on the deck and with the left hand he
feels it to pick his try to kill him
Coco he has made have to come to the
confidence Department oh my goodness
confidence not a problem for Carl
Anthony towns gets hammered as he throws
down the jam in towns where they don't
want to go here in the third he gets he
gets angry and that's what it takes him
he got hit right in the face and you
know is that a flagrant foul I mean like
Marc Gasol hit him four to shoot
Wiggins has to go Wiggins pull-up jumper
no town to rebound but to fly at the
buzzer I can't a strapping finish for
the Grizzlies look
[Music]
towns what great awareness to get him
out of his hands and he got it away in
time they will count the bucket the
Timberwolves are walk-off winners
[Applause]
karl-anthony towns Jim he was in foul
trouble all night but he came up big
excellent job by pulling it out there
and hedge on Andrew Wiggins get back to
his own town trying to take advantage
with Yogi's out of the game just infused
basic level in Chesterton right there
get out of my way town oh my goodness
that was devastated 27 in the quarter
karl-anthony towns did his best to keep
the Timberwolves close picked up by
Simmons
[Music]
[Applause]
start over
and then in transition the reach-back
katmandu transition darío wide open
Carly he just has that knack of being
able to find that scene if you don't put
a body on him like all great offensive
rebounders I love it man burritos with a
block man did he get up for that put
right into the hands of every of the
town's influences that one as well last
lead was in the second quarter 57 56 two
moles would like to keep it that way
don't work underneath gets it back from
rose
and town's able to get the reach-in foul
on O'Quinn a great move by towns and
that's gonna be the third personal in
the game I don't quit shot clock down to
four oke Oke
gives it up towns lets it fly and
connects he tries to make something
happen off the dribble Karl gets out of
his way but then spots up and that is
young for some reason comes off he said
Nietzsche Lika Dodgers his Tallis boys
Bebe's are helping spa play concern open
about that the problem is the schedule
is not gonna get any no your simple
seven whoa oh my goodness karl-anthony
towns he's not human
karl-anthony towns elevating how fun is
this
Tim rolls leading the Thunder by 15
can't get enough a look at towns
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is that hey it's goes high dribble over
the shoulder of Paul George times wives
it up and throws it down
over the Oklahoma City Thunder
Jonathas knocking on the door of a 16th
straight double-double he's got 15
points eight boards times what a heads
on a play count the bucket and add one
chance for a four-point play as Bruce
brown reaches in CP pump fakes aziza to
state Wow that the presence of my
Bartman moment there of course the
stakes not nearly as high away from the
Wizards because we wouldn't see this
point that's gonna be on these dogs
right back on the baseline I think I
think all the details listen to the
broadcast he's trying to prove something
out here second quarter he goes baseline
hauling bushes and yes we call that a
reverse Jam any grounds that even after
the double would but can we see the
first dog and that's a good shot for him
because he's a guy that can heat up
quickly and you know they D up with the
pass to cat for the halleluh him balls
only plays of warriors in this building
one time last season
[Applause]
phlex like that though karl-anthony
towns swinging it and the walls with the
six-point advantage early in quarter
number one turns it over to rinse down
two times furnace times ticking on to
mark Greene he's just a tremendous
defender times gets back in the floor
and who gets the and secures the rebound
off the town's blocking anytime they are
not going to let Carl Anthony towns hurt
them and post up situation sites it's
one of those chances get out of here
rookie karl-anthony towns he knows he
knows that Luca wants to get to the rim
towns
that's his third tuck tonight
karl-anthony towns by the way has gone
over a hundred dunks on the season just
a little bit too much on it fro kogi
Timberwolves get it back to Jones he'll
try a three sharks and offensive
rebounds to big yet too strong but the
dragons could do about that Carla J
times the drop-down by Dario and he's
gonna get double figures points and he
has the ball so much most likely got
[Applause]
hammered on captor made baskets and how
about off of a made basket good job of
throwing the ball ahead towns finishing
over Adams take that what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content